how are we getting on do you think 1.5
degrees is actually
um is actually
attainable
yes i do
um and not only do i think it's
obtainable but i very much agree with
your last uh interviewee
it has to be
attainable because it's not just the
marshall islands or those that would
disappear
were it not to be attained but as she
says behind them
are very many other communities
places like bangladesh which are
entirely beneath the um
sea level
large parts of the united states and of
europe where
great cities will be losing very large
sections
all that we have to defend
and uh it's i'm afraid
a battle which we just have to win it's
like in that sense the battle of britain
we cannot possibly lose it
does the fact that we we are missing
some of the big players here in glasgow
president xi president putin president
baltonaro
uh is that going to make a difference to
what can come out of this uh this event
well
it'd be much better if they were there
although i'm not sure president
bolsonaro would raise the standard much
but the fact of the matter is that in
the end these countries are going to be
just as affected and i'm very interested
to see that the
chinese are moving all the time because
they actually believe in climate change
they understand what huge damage it's
doing to their own country and
president xi has already made a number
of steps it's not good enough yet but
they've committed to net zero
and they've
made it clear that they're not now going
to support uh the production of
coal-fired power stations outside their
own land and they are increasing the
amount of in a huge way the amount of
offshore wind and
solar that they're installing and we
have to remember that their emissions
are our emissions i mean we have
exported our manufacture to china and we
are buying those goods so this is an
issue which we can't entirely shovel off
to them
um
the the president designates uh
alexander is not not a person who um
let's put it this way puts his emotions
out there but he seemed to me talking to
him a little earlier
rather frustrated by the fact that what
we seem to get again and again is a lot
of promises from these countries but not
always the action that he would like how
how
can he make sure that um the next two
weeks aren't just in the words of greta
tonberg a lot of blah blah blah
well i mean this is one of the big
problems isn't it the the british
government i must say and i have
certainly not been a uh
undoubted supporter of it the british
government has taken the step which
everyone has to take which is to turn
its commitments into the first step of a
net zero
program and the climate change committee
is going to keep the government's feet
to the fire we've also made it statutory
we have to do it by law so that the
government can be held to account in the
courts so we have done those things i'd
quite agree there are some other things
we shouldn't have done which hadn't
helped but that we have done and those
are the things which we've got to see
from other nations in their own way in
their own systems but in a way which we
know is really going to deliver
is one of the things that our government
should not have done is to reduce
airport taxes to make in order to make
domestic
flights uh less expensive
well i'm afraid the government is hung
up in trying to prove that leaving the
european union was a good idea
and that's quite difficult and so one of
the things it can do is to reduce the
taxes internally and not across the
whole of europe so it decides to do that
actually it doesn't make any difference
as a matter of technicality because the
way that internal flights are accounted
for under climate change will mean that
they'll just have to pay more in carbon
so it's not carbon tax so actually it's
not going to make all that difference
but it was perhaps not the right thing
to do i think it's less important
than remembering that they have
increased the cost of long
haul fights
and remembering also that the biggest
mistake that was made was to cut our
overseas aid from 0.7 to 0.5 which
doesn't give people confidence that
we're going to help people in the way
we've promised to do and that for me was
a really deeply immoral and unacceptable
act
it sounds to me lord that what you're
saying is that in spite of uh our own
governments
i'm afraid to let use that phrase again
blah blah blah the action that follows
is at least um neutral it isn't
necessarily uh pointing in the direction
that you uh want to want the government
to to go in terms of uh
improving the prospects of getting to
1.5 degrees essentially what you're
saying is
government says it says it's going to do
the right thing but actually
in what it does
it's heading in the wrong direction
now i don't agree with that at all i
haven't said that i've said it's made
mistakes but then every government does
this is the one government that says
nothing but electric cars or the
equivalent after 2030. this is the
government that has an actual strategy
to reach net zero and a policy and
program to do it this is the government
that's made that legally binding this is
the first government to sign up to net
zero in 2050. this is a government that
has got a policy for building and
heating in
in its own country which no other
government has this is a government
which is out on the front line and is
doing the right things which every now
and again makes mistakes and one of the
problems with the press is that we hear
very too much too little a thank you for
getting bits right and always
concentrating things get wrong now my
trouble is that i'm the chairman of the
climate change committee and my job is
to keep the government feet to the fire
and make sure that it goes on doing the
right things and avoids doing the wrong
things but it doesn't mean that i don't
respect the fact that this government
has committed itself in a way which no
other government has and parliament has
supported it whereas joe biden for
example has rejoined the world in this
remarkable way but he's having terrible
trouble getting his own legislature to
give him the support that we need if
we're going to stop the world from
disaster and disaster it is don't
undercut i don't undermine this this is
a
one chance we have to save the world
i get i get that uh and you say
this is the government that's done this
this and this uh well let's take one
example electric cars yup they've made a
pledge on electric cars but i think your
own committee says
that we've got 26 000 charging uh points
we really need 450 000 now
is there any possibility that we're
actually going to hit that
in time
well i've been lucky enough to have an
electric car as a matter of fact and all
i can tell you is that the advance in
the charging arrangements are is
enormous
and i have had no trouble at all using
it uh my problem is that we've got to
move to a situation in which those cars
are within the uh
ability of everyone to buy as against
petrol cars and the biggest change
so i don't want to interrupt you but um
my co one of my colleagues here at sky
tried to drive from did drive from
london to glasgow and what he discovered
is that one in 10 charging points even
of the 26 000 at any given time isn't
working we really haven't got the
infrastructure to deliver
well with i mean
i don't want to be put into a position
of defending the government because i'm
not
i'm an independent and i don't defend
the government and the government could
do a great deal more all i'm saying is
that in the context of the world this
government has been doing a great deal
my job is to make sure that it does more
and more and on the charging front there
is a great deal more to be done not
least to making it easier to have a
charge because unfortunately they're run
by different people with different
mechanisms and that's barmy so we have
to put that right and the truth is that
some motor cars have been made by people
who've made better provision and we've
got to think about how we have uh
superchargers for everybody they're all
those things that need to be done the
government is
on the way to doing that and our job is
not to say you haven't done it yet it is
to say that we want more now we want
more next month and we want more the
month after and you've got to meet the
target which the climate change
committee has set